and we are live good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
sidere your Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel
where where is Young Harris what
what here he comes here he comes were
you in the basement again sir it happens
you
know right how are we all we're up Paris
doing well doing well look haris his
tiny little head look look at him
thought he was small before now look at
him you
know so chaps we are here to discuss
some slightly bad news it's not it's not
great news let's be honest um I haven't
shared the video can anybody in the
comments like share the video for me
because I forgot um but we are going to
talk about the news that I dropped uh
midweek um I haven't done a video about
it yet because I'm desperately trying
trying to sort of get more information
on it so we have to dump this very
firmly in the um uh rumor category I'm
going to say that repeatedly in this
video rumor category I I've only got one
source on it but I have been able to
find a couple of other bits and pieces
about um the executive that from MGM
that apparently said
it very SP trying to find out if it's
the sort of thing he would do and
apparently very much so um he's he's
he's known as a little bit of a
hotthead so so that LE gives me a little
bit more um in you know support that
actually this isn't out of character so
I'll very quickly say what happened or
what what uh the source I spoken to um
says happened and then I've sort of
broke it down into a few bits I want to
discuss if that's cool with you guys you
have oh um Melvin thank you very much
for joining us today by the way Ma join
he's had a really shitty week at work so
Melvin has stepped in and stormmy is
still not well guys so please I still
haven't been on a live with
stormmy really he hates you Melvin
saying he's actually infected his own
boner just to not be on a video with you
it was because I asked him that time
about the ion thrusters weren it yeah
yeah he's never letting that [__] go hey
Michael hey Davey hey Laura hey secular
mon Michael Kerry uh Bob's in rich is in
I think I said Laura Paul Maloney's in
Sarah Oilers in hello bat Mall the Gat
is in so yes this news was dropped on
the Wednesday live video when Michael
kept dropping out on me C Harris
discussed it on Cinema scoop just after
in a bit more
detail but basically what happened is
one of my uh sources that works over at
one of the larger agencies was having a
meeting with um an MGM MGM plus
executive a senior MGM plus executive is
as much as I can really say fairly uh
the meeting was about talking and
discussing what projects are going to be
potentially affected by the redundancies
that were announced so bunch of
redundancies MGM and Amazon and um a big
that a load of rances over one of their
a um Asian
side of things um and they basically say
look what is going to be affected if
anything um as that meeting went on they
started talking about what upcoming
projects were going to be affected and
this senior
executive got a bit heated and um they
did say that basically uh the movie for
Stargate Robo Cop um and a couple of
others that were planned to be announced
in the next couple of months have been
put on hold
so
um they just and and he actually went on
as far as saying that they he thinks
Stargate because obviously my source
immediately went a Stargate I love
Stargate can we talk about that um and
he basically said like he doesn't think
the Stargate mov is gonna
happen we'll talk about why in a minute
but first of all like the Stargate movie
and RoboCop to be honest as well because
I was just as much I was just like [__]
man I'm looking forward to that as well
um what what what what's your first
instinct for one do you think that's a
good idea and for
two can you understand maybe
whyin you go for it well I got a little
bit on Cinema scoop on Wednesday so
Melvin you go for it well I mean I mean
I could understand it but I mean the
movie wasn't the one thing that everyone
was wants is it the one thing everyone
wants is the show
so and the fact that MGM plus is being
such a pain in the ass
it's uh yeah I'll just I've lost
interest in MGM plus because we we're
not going to get it over here anyway but
this is nothing sh we do get it over
here MGM plus is on Amazon Prime well I
know we get MGM but we don't get we're
not gettingg are we not as the pl indiv
independent platform we do it's on it's
4.99 it's on yeah it's on Amazon it's
the same as the American version just on
Amazon it's just MGM isn't it it's not
MGM
is
itgm but it's
not it's pretty much the same content
yeah yeah well that's just moved over
but the ggm plus is the replacement for
that then yeah because we never had
epics over here we already had an MGM
service didn't we before that
yeah I'm gonna have to have a look
actually is it not MGM plus definitely
not even realize just
MGM
yeah I've got it I've never looked never
I never noticed that I don't know um I
don't ever I never come become a police
detective because someone's gonna get
murdered and go it happened in front of
you did it I wasn't I think it was even
announced when they announced MGM plus
officially it was announced that it's
was going to be in America First and it
may or may not go
Global Buton was always intending to
keep MGM for especially for the rest of
the world it is supposed to be
translating across into other um
networks this year and next year
apparently Amazon are pushing for a big
why did they get the
content yeah the
content Happy Days um yeah
[Laughter]
um um well well this is um I ate David
be was annoying two so is it two1 then
Dave
we don't I just talked to somebody
yesterday about um as find in towns end
about 30
minutes um about how the the most
clicked video I've got is when Liverpool
lost 70 oh we lost seven to Liverpool
it's the most clipped video I've ever
had that was the most fun stream every
four or five minutes you're just getting
angrier and angrier it's
gr if um the one question I suppose I
asked ask though is the is I I know the
reasons I was given for why this MGM
executive believes the the movie is
being
cancelled why do you guys do you have
any reasons why you think if you if like
I say if you were an Amazon executive
why would you cancel it and guys get
into the comments as well and tell me
what what you
think are there reasons why this may be
is different from 12 months ago
what I mean I kind of touched on a
little bit on Cinema scoop after we
talked about it the other day was just I
mean I know as Stargate people we are
probably preferring a series over a film
but the reason I've been so gung-ho
about a film is strictly because of the
the confidence aspect of it that means
the studio behind it cares for this they
they've worked on it they they've put
the effort into like knowing what they
actually have and what it could do and
this this is what I was worried about
all along I I know I mentioned it the
other day was if it goes to MGM plus if
we actually get a TV series on MGM plus
we're going to get two maybe three
seasons of it before it gets canceled n
the five balls are going to get on it
the and if it goes to Prime everybody's
going to watch it for a week or they're
all going to subscribe to MGM Plus for a
week maybe a month to watch it and then
toss that right back out that's not GNA
be making any money for Amazon or a
third the amount they want a quarter of
the amount they want half the amount
what they want whatever it may be I just
think it's it ends up showing how
worried they are instead of the the
confidence aspect of it obviously
but the the the lack of willingness to
give us something on our screens I think
comes from that
and I I don't know it just it makes me
sad it pisses me off but it also makes
me sad just I I just wish that the
studio would actually do something with
it they know what they have it's they've
wasted it it's become a nothing Burger
the more we talk about a series over a
movie and the more they fiddle their
thumbs it becomes more of a nothing
Burger I the more we talk about a series
I strongly do not think we're ever going
to get anything starting again until
it's gonna be another 10 15 20 years
from now we need to talk about a movie I
think it's time to talk I think it's
squarely in that field at this point
again and the Studio's decision making
as of
recent is that icing on the cake there I
hate to say is the reason though why
maybe Amazon are hesitating and and and
and and Melvin you I'd love to know
you're thinking on this is it because
their decision making has been bloody
awful in the last say five or six years
and if you've getting movies that cost
$300 million and have barely taken a 100
million at the box office it's made them
stop and
think yeah rightly so that's what I
think because um I mean movies have lost
a lot in the last five years right I
mean how much how many billions is
Disney lost in the last movies last
several movies that they've made besides
Avatar 2 the third highest grossing film
ever yeah exactly yeah but has struggled
well I know to be fair Disney's been at
is at a roller coaster if we're gonna be
fair about
itting the Beast made a load of money
well even if we're talking recent
Ant-Man sucked and it didn't make a
whole bunch of money but Guardians made
$800 million not not as much as You'
want or necessarily expect but it did
just fine Elemental didn't make a bunch
of money at first but came back and made
plenty of money wish didn't do as well
as people probably wanted it to but it
made money they're they're they're not
as bad quote unquote as we from from the
public Z guys from our public opinion it
feels like they're in the place that we
want to put them in and they're
definitely reaching that point but we
are hyperbolizing it a bit they've not
had the hit after hit that they were
getting seven eight years ago though it
feels like Marvel movie was billion
dollars every Star Wars thing was making
a bit you know what I mean so that's why
I think where Melvin's got a good
point they are
stuttering their own rules Disney
specifically said what Bob Iger said in
on you know live he said that if the if
a movie doesn't make a billion
dollars full stop it's a
failure I'm blocking
paulone
but yeah no it's true I mean and and
that's where we were five or six years
ago films was getting to a point where
the film had to make a billion dollars
or mean how much the first Avatar movie
make uh
2009 yeah and they wereing make three
billion on this W they they made two
yeah but just fail cons compared to the
first Avatar Avatar to was it the way of
water wasn't as good it it's been too
long since the first one came out it I
don't know I don't I don't I think the
entire world would oppose that they were
surfing they were all like you know
splashing each other and
um another world it didn't necessarily
reinvent the script from beforehand but
I think it added a lot to that world and
it did a lot of it did what it wanted I
think James Cameron was in the bath with
writing a script and he dropped it and
he went Eureka I'll just do the first
film
weather and and that and and it made two
billion dollar so Happy
Days um the reason the executive
apparently when he went on a little bit
of a rant um he did say that there there
was there was definitely a feeling in
all of the studios um that Cinema
changed and it's basically took
Executives about two years to Twig that
everything after covid in particular
our habits have
changed not just covid though because
covid and streaming I think we discussed
this didn't we on Wednesday Harris but
social habits changed social habits
changed the last years um so we and that
streaming covid um the internet
generally um you know because obviously
we've been living with the internet a
long time now but the last five years or
so with 4G and all this sort of thing
it's really got to a point where you can
stream straight to your phone you can
it's it's gone to that next level sort
of thing and something else that I don't
think the studios and Executives
actually understand is the the
advancement that's of that people like
us have in on YouTube and other
platforms is that people will wait until
we say something about something so if
we say um there's a channel that will go
out they'll watch a film they'll go to
they'll pay to go to the cinema and
they'll tell them whether it's good or
bad and then they'll tell them what
story is more than what the synopsis
says and then they'll then the people
will decide I might go and see that but
they'll wait until after People Like Us
have done a video especially the
YouTubers generally speaking and YouTube
influencers have become way more
powerful today than they were five years
ago exactly well I mean even even you
they're talking about the the Disney um
how people just think Disney are just
losing billions and billions do and
don't get me wrong they lost a shitload
of money because of um
Disney a billion dollars a year
basically was it three $400 million a
quarter at one point um so they lost a
lot of money because of that but because
there are a lot of hate clicking
YouTubers out there that really really
hate Disney it is be it is creating this
almost false attitude that every single
Disney movie in the last five years has
bombed and been a woke joke f and it's
not they are making money still not as
much as they were but they are not as
successful as they used to the five
years before that though no no they've
they've been tripping on their own
shelac as a
fair so it does feel that the Amazon
particularly during the strikes like
every other Studio don't get me wrong
them canceling or or at least putting
Stargate Robocop and other things on the
back burner is it shouldn't really be a
massive shock because every other Studio
has done virtually exactly the same
thing they've quietly I mean I know
about starting RoboCop because I'm
interested in it I've got sources that
are able to tell me about it but I can
tell you if we were able to get into the
offices of every other Studio there's
aund other projects that would have been
announced by now that PA they're backing
off because the studios had too long to
think about it with Disney and a couple
of others projects that are made and
finished they're not going to release
because of this tax write off thing that
they realiz they can make a bit of money
on
and the fan
backlash well yeah um there has been a
fan backlash so um but you know we're
the Star Wars we're in a different world
right now than we were preco and pre
streaming and he says that's one reason
why this is
happening I would argue that maybe
Amazon have listen to
MGM they were kept making the argument
that the series is what people actually
want so it might just be an element of
that did you think that maybe has some
legs that they've just listened gone the
evidence isn't there to support that a
movie will be
successful but a
series their in- house is too messy to
even do a series I think that's the
biggest thing at the end of the day
their in-house is far too messy to do a
series and from what we know as just the
the audience and the people that are
paying Prime customers and potential
paying MGM plus customers realistically
we we keep clamoring for a series nobody
wants a series nobody wants to go on MGM
plus that we're all lying to ourselves
I'm sorry to say it but the more we say
we want a series we want a series but
I'm not paying for MGM plus you don't
want a
series you you want it within your own
confines and if that's going to happen
if you want it to be that big to be put
on prime it needs a movie I I I truly
believe we got to start clamoring for a
film or we're not going to get started
it's spooky at this point like like we
talked about earlier Bob I think made
the joke we're edging ourselves at this
point over and over and that's excuse
the term but it's it's it's a fitting
term
like
well I mean the original plan of having
this sort of franchise thing where it
would be a couple of movies a couple of
TV series they'd film the whole thing in
two or three sound
Studios if we assume the movie is done
that we assume that that movie that plan
is done and I can tell you that
apparently according to somebody else
that Amazon has already spent um $10
million on starget um new franchise
that's $10 million they've already spent
that's just a gate yeah just building a
gate and paying for an original script
to be done it looked like they we we're
reasonably certain some um prop work and
stuff was done um and things and they
were they were gearing up towards
filming the movie and summer it's that
now that's nothing like what Netflix
spent $30 million preparing to do He-Man
yeah
Justman yeah I was I was I'm so gooded
we're not getting a he-man live action
movie I really really wanted it
um and I understand where you're coming
from Harris we talking about a
movie one of your arguments through the
day was though that if this goes on MGM
plus we'll get three seasons and they'll
cancel it and if we get three I think
you are wrong I think it will purely be
based on whether this is successful or
not and they will show it on Prime as
well they'll just show it on Prime after
they show on MGM
plus those numbers affect MGM plus
though will they sorry those prime
numbers won't affect MGM plus though
they're not getting the money from that
they would if it was on MGM plus and if
people are waiting for it to go on Prime
there's no reason to ever get MGM Plus
I think see it is that they're getting
paid twice I think that's the way no
one's no one's GNA pay the first time
for MGM plus if it's going to go on
Prime people wait people wait six eight
nine months for a movie to not they
don't go to a theater because they can
wait at home they're can they're gonna
wait six eight nine months if it if if
it's on MGM plus and it's not reaching
the Zeitgeist that it should because if
it's on MGM plus it will not be getting
the Twitter it won't be getting the
Instagram it won't be getting the social
media run that it should it won't get
anywhere near the social media run that
it should I do have a question just
realized what's happened to this
Stargate dedicated
channel on Amazon
Prime did we ever get that on um
free I don't think so MGM plus never
came here it was it was announced wasn't
it it was going to be on in the states
at least
definitely because I thought the
Stargate Des the Stargate specific
Channel what would only have Stargate on
repeat would be was an experiment to see
what the uh interest was but it never as
far as I'm aware didn't get they just
put on MGM Plus instead but MGM Plus in
America has doubled its subscription in
12 months more than doubled its
subscription in 12 months like this joke
we made on Wednesday I know eight but
apparently
Amazon sorry Amazon exec are quite
excited and um and and like I said to
you um in the week as well when they've
done um like satisfaction surveys MGM
scores like second or third out of all
of the streaming services but MGM plus
MGM plus yeah that when they look at it
and they go this costs five quid and
I've got all these classic MGM movies
and blah blah blah and it scores really
really high in satisfaction so Amazon
look at that and go well if we can keep
the price at that but advertise it like
crazy this this could be as biggest
freee it could be but like we talked
about on Wednesday if they're going to
have their MGM products on Prime and
have it for free on Prime no one's going
to be paying that extra five dollars for
the products they can just buy on prime
or not mean buy just wash on
Prime put it this way then as well MGM
plus you're mic right and you you run
MGM plus right and Amazon are telling
you that we're going to get MGM IP and
it's going to appear on MGM plus first
the channel is growing already I mean
epic was a reasonably what was it like
ninth largest I think or something like
that in America when it was
epics so whatever it is now oh there's a
cat um so if you're so if you're Mike
right and you're running this do you
want Stargate and will you absolutely
fight your ball get it oh I totally
would and that's part of the issue is
that he wants it for MGM Plus and he
he's thinking about his streaming
service and Amazon is thinking about a
streaming service instead of thinking
about what's best for the show and
that's the issue at hand is that they're
it's what what do we always say as film
people it doesn't matter exactly what
the genre is or anything script and
Story come first
yep be thinking Stargate is this it's
the sleep and giant of sci-fi this could
be our Star Trek
I want it on MGM plus and and if I want
MGM plus to grow I need a show like
Stargate I need something so if they're
going to do their due diligence it's
probably going to take two years maybe
three to actually put all this together
and all that and it's taken two or three
years just to decide if we're going to
get it on Amazon or MGM plus if they're
going to do their due diligence and do
it right and they haven't even started
the whole they they might have some
pre-production but if they don't have
any pre-production or or very minimal
amount of it already done that that
means they still have to build all that
that means they have to get the studio
space they have to do etc etc etc
etc
just and well I'm telling you now for
for the next thing on the on the sort of
like the story goes is that MGM Plus
have got um a are looking at Stargate
they they are looking at doing a series
which we knew that anyway the idea was
that it was supposed to be in
conjunction with the movie apparently
I'm being told they're still looking at
the
series um but it won't be this year
it'll it'll be next year it'll go it
might go on the development list slate
but the development slate is not going
to be
released on if if this decision hasn't
made the earliest we get it is 2027 I I
think 2026 is even the if we push it
another three months the earliest is
gonna be
2027 I love massive
cat's
the entire screen there we go it was a
full blackout on the screen I was
waiting for that yeah this is why I'm a
dog person mate the dogs do as they're
told cats do what they want um I I think
there's already been a lot of
development and stuff work done towards
the series on me I I don't think this is
going to be 2026 2027 I think this will
go into full-blown development next year
and we'll see it by the end of next year
and as soon as we get an announcement a
TV show can be on our screens in nine
months
right they've theyve they have done a
lot of work on this
already
um the problem is um the cat wants to
tell us
something yeah he wanted something to
he's been out all all bloody day and you
know just yeah come running in like that
it's crazy dogs treat you like family
cats treat you like staff yeah yeah
that's good yeah they do they do I agree
yeah my dog just loves me your cat is
just thinking why aren't you feeding me
right now what what how dare you not be
looking at me stupid cat um but anyway
um you Noti when he came on he didn't
actually look at
me what's going on over here the cat
wants Stargate as well yeah he does um
okay so so the caveat that I would say
is something that could go on MGM plus
that I think would be a a good thing for
MGM Plus would get a bunch of eyes on it
especially the Stargate eyes which if
those are the eyes they want they don't
have to spend a whole bunch of money on
it we've talked about it before do a Min
series do your main series on Prime
promote your miniseries on whether it's
a prequel whether it's of an ancillary
tertiary secondary character whoever the
hell you want to do whatever the hell
you want to do put a little miniseries
over on MGM plus and use that if if if
they want to play the long game which is
seemingly is what they want to play
because it's taken two or three years to
make a freaking decision and we're not
even there yet
so make the series make the movie make a
series and and at some point you can do
the miniseries before you do the series
but promote that on Prime and put the
miniseries on MGM plus bridge the gap
that's how you bridge a gap if you want
to play the long game play the long game
but just don't don't sell the franchise
to Apple please actually I don't know
but that'd be a whole different
conversation can't
you do for me what I would do if again
if I was in charge of if if my name's
Jeff hello Mr Bezos and I want MGM plus
to do well because we get all of aing
from Prime anyway no one's canceling
Prime but we want a bit extra to Ching
from MGM plus I would do a miniseries
that I put on
prime with a cliffhanger that then the
next season that goes straight to MGM
plus starts on and I'm sorry mate I
don't care how many of you are out there
going I'm not paying for another
streaming service enough people will
enough enough people will but then you
hit that Disney aspect is do you lose
fan Goodwill at that point you're
essentially forcing our hand to pay you
more money instead of saying okay that's
why I said it the other way at first is
like all right we still have Prime we're
paying the primary of our dollars this
is a $10 a month thing $5 a month for
the extra bid if we want that cherry on
top we can go grab it if we want our
whipped cream on our ice cream we can go
get it but it's it's an option and and
we will all [__] about it but enough of
us will do it that's all they can Disney
they know loads of people [__] about it
but they don't really care because
enough people are doing it they can C in
crowds in their own's Parks
so you what what sorry Mel they can
actually AF they can afford the CGI in
crowds at their own Parks yeah they
don't yeah that that's that's not not
not but yeah okay not the best thing for
them to actually let people find out
about is it CG crows in their own parts
for me if I was Amazon what I'd be doing
is I'd be doing a TV movie of Star game
come on he's a little
rasal a rasal I've been doing a TV movie
like 40 50
[Music]
millionar like what Star Trek are doing
with section 31 and The Bard movie
that's what I would do you can do a
two-hour
episode for about $30 million that looks
or $40 million that Star Trek sort of
level looks which is pretty which is
damn near Cinema cinemagraphic it's
pretty good it'll look fine on the small
screen and do that um and at least then
you'll build some hype you'll get some
excitement but they don't even want to
do
that why just just for the sake of
questions what why why would you put a
TV movie in there especially esecially
when streaming is it's not looking as
good as it did a year and a half ago
three years ago I I disagree I think
streaming is kicking Cinema's ass at the
moment there there's a reason Netflix
just introduced it might might streaming
might be doing a lot more the numbers
are going down for streaming too there's
a reason Netflix just introduced all the
ad tier people people need to want to
watch things they don't want to pay
money to watch things so they want to
pay cheaper amounts and so on and so
forth I think that's a twofold problem
we are still living through
a cost of living crisis which there
there is that there are also too many
streaming services so people are picking
their
favorites um so there is an element of
that as well um but how many people
remember the days when there was just
two yeah like when there was only four
channels on the tell but youve got to
remember though as well Netflix's
business model is built on continuous
growth and their growth was starting to
slow I even they didn't even they had
actually decreases for a couple of
months in a row didn't they didn't lose
like a million subscribers one month and
everyone was like oh c end of Netflix
they put the adverts in and it's shut up
by six million um so I mean and they
changed the password thing and they put
the password thing was going to kill
them and it didn't their subscription
number shot up but their business model
is based on continuous growth they they
can't stagnate so that's why they've
done it but Netflix have come out the
best well now streaming Wars well now
Netflix their model isn't entirely based
on growth now their largest base of
subscribers is and add Revenue
tier they've changed their entire model
into a cable aspect of a network all
these streaming services are leaning
closer and closer to Cable we're going
back to it I don't think TV mov so just
just because hindsight's 2020 that's
what I like to say uh but just because I
came in so late for the whole Stargate
crew you know I had to grow up first and
then I was oh wait this is a thing uh
and now I adore it but after I finished
starget sg1 those two TV movies were
disappointing and I really wish they not
truly disappointing I had a good time
but I feel like in scope and scale they
were disappointing in the sense of both
of those could and probably should have
been actual films especially with how
big Stargate was at the time spend an
extra $20 $20 spend an extra $20 million
or $10 million whatever just give it a
little bit more of a budget not a whole
bunch just enough put in theaters and we
probably would have finished SGA we
probably would have finished SGU that
was the case there probably would have
been enough Goodwill to continue I think
we would be shooting ourselves in the
foot and there was a business model that
changed basically on them there wasn't
there there was a business model to put
on DVDs and I actually think what they
should have done immediately was just
picked up the phone and phone Netflix
and Netflix would have paid for it
because that would have been good at the
time shooted up and
then my worry with the TV movie My worry
with sending it to MGM plus how did
Stargate actually die the first time it
listened to
MGM excuse my
French I'm not even G to say f MGM I was
going to I was gonna say just [__]
whatever screw MGM completely they're I
love I love the company it's an amazing
company they put out some of the best
films that have ever been made and they
will hopefully continue to do so but
there's a reason they have been on the
verge of bankruptcy for a long time and
there's a reason reason they did end up
selling off everything to other people
besides the Vegas casinos they made some
horrendous business decisions
particularly in the 80s don't think the
leftovers are making good decisions
still yeah well you could argue that but
um no you could yeah yeah I think that's
a
arum entire
Pointes until they were until what what
was it um 2015 they were
nightmare yeah absolute nightmare until
about 2015 and then they improved and
2015 the year that we almost got the
Stargate reboot by the way so luckily
that didn't happen yeah the one thing
this executive that was um chatting to
um my friend um is he saying that one of
the things they're really furious at MGM
is that they feel like particularly
starting a couple of other projects you
mentioned as well have been a massively
wasted
opportunity that there was loads of
momentum and loads of really good
positive um public interest in things
like Stargate and it's waned because
people got bored waiting look at all the
interest when Amazon bought MGM
everybody went nuts well where Stargate
Stargate will be around the corner
brilliant two years it was the whole
reason I got into Stargate yeah so I
mean two years has gone by now and even
on this channel where we're pretty much
hardcore star Gators we're getting sick
of this I if you've noticed I don't talk
about Stargate anything like as much as
I did because even I'm getting irritated
by it um and I know what's going on I I
like say I know a few things I can't
share so I'm still confident we're going
to get this this year but or we're gonna
get something really exciting this
year but even I'm sort of like bangam
against a brick wall it feels
like you know is is there how much of
that can be ched up MGM sorry how much
of that can be chalked up to MGM
actually
prolonging this out and and keeping it
from actually happening Amon this was
100% Amazon mate and the end of when
Amazon bought MGM MGM were allowed to
believe that they were going to continue
being able to allow to to do the
projects they had lined up they continue
to work on Stargate they continued to
work on Brad Stargate and they continued
to work on second project and they
thought they were going to be allowed to
Green like this as soon as the sale had
got through FTC they could get the money
sorted weren't going to start spending
money until the FCC had sort of like
said all thumbs up and then they thought
they were going to be allowed to crack
on with it and the second the fdc's do
shut and they went okay like you know
the hammer came down agreed Amazon went
oh we've changed our minds actually
we're going to absorb MGM and we're
basically going to wipe MGM as a
business you're only going to be a brand
and they absorbed it and they blamed
covid I'm not taking the big giant
corporations side I'm just trying to be
realistic as as I'm trying to be with
this entire thing it's not like he wants
to work for them at some point well I'd
like to work for him more than I would
I'd rather have an MGM lying behind my
name than I would at Amazon Prime if I'm
in a movie or TV show but you
realistically if Amazon Prime Amazon in
general is buying you one of the largest
companies in the world and you don't
physically sign papers that say you're
keeping our entire company together and
like it's because if if they if they
would have had to contractually keep MGM
together the way they did did we lose a
soccer goal or something oops uh
football oops whatever I'm saying
uh uh but I lost my friend of thought
what was I saying uh Newport County had
scored two goals against man we're in
the Premiership Newport County are one
Welsh and two four leagues blow us just
saying [__] Stargate that's it I'm done
I'm out of here [__]
it um unfortunate some of those smaller
clubs are really good clubs that's the
problem shut up
some well I'm gonna keep my comment to
myself then what I was about to say new
fan I can
admit just just let me
vent okay that's where my thought
process was so I mean if we're just
being realistic how big corporations
work MGM was kidding themselves if they
actually 100% believe that if if it was
not contractually signed written down in
writing that MGM was going to stay its
own thing if it was just promises made
in boardroom and handshakes and and and
word of mouth instead of physical
writing on a piece of paper MGM MGM was
never going to stay MGM it was always
going to be absorbed the Amazon people
never thought that they were that was
just a negotiating tactic at best if it
was not written down Pam Abdi and Mike
Duca were out the the second the FDC
decision ended Pam Abdi and Mike Duca
were gone and that was because the rumor
is it was because they realized they'd
been lied to and it was them all the MGM
staff were looking at them going you've
been telling us for six months this was
going to be fine well and they went and
they just they just left I understand
being upset but that's about as naive as
someone can be when dealing with Amazon
Amazon that's that's just as about as
naive as anybody that's running a
company can be and if you're that naive
running a company as good as some of the
stuff you might have done is you
shouldn't be running a
company I'm just being frank at the end
of the day so with that being said
because because because I would have
loved Brad Wright to come in there and
had the immediate like because
everything was ready to roll so that
would have been amazing but because the
naivity was there and Amazon did Amazon
being big giant Corporation they've put
in all this work is MGM keeping us from
getting Stargate now now after that
decision was made because Amazon kept us
from getting Stargate originally but now
is it vice versa in the fact that Mike
Wright is just wanting okay we got to
get this on GM plus we want to do this
here that's prolonging a legitimate
decision from happening is I'm just the
minimal facts I have is that's just what
my no I see where you I see where your
argument is coming from is it is it is
the argument between MGM plus and Amazon
slowing things down I would I would
argue that amaz is going to do what they
want an MGM PL MGM as an empty barely
exists as a separate entity anymore MGM
plus only exists as it is because it's a
channel within in the same respect that
freey has a head um and for the channel
so they they can make the argument but
at the end of the day it's Jennifer saly
and people like that that are making and
Mike Hopkins and people like that that
are making the decisions okay just
because just because Mike C is making an
argument don't mean he he ain't getting
anything he'll get what Amazon give him
I honestly think
Amazon the only reason Stargate was
getting a movie was because Amazon had a
billion dollars a year they were going
to spend on movies and they're still not
really doing that they're not putting
movies at the cinema and that was
announced what two years
ago that Cinema's changed and I think
the people at Amazon are now going well
if if we do that we're just we we just
burn a billion dollars we can do a movie
Roadhouse Roadhouse has just been Jake
Gillan Hall everyone's talking about
this being awards ceremony and last
minute they've gone yeah we're not
putting that at the cinema we're going
to put it straight on
Prime um and and
everyone yeah everyone's gone nuts over
it a they but but I think that
is is is an example of the
symptom not just Amazon but other
Studios that they're looking at the
cinema and going if we put a movie at
the cinema we're just flushing our to
and money down the toilet there's no
point we may as well put it on the
streaming service straight away put it
behind a firewall at first you know put
it behind a pay wall at first and people
and and then put it on Prime and it'll
make the
money it's not worth putting money in
the cin you can't lose money you don't
make money by putting anything on TV
movies on like like like Tarantino
literally just put a whole statement out
was like Ryan Reynolds has made five
Netflix movies he he got the money they
paid him but how much money have any of
those movies made are you and then he
made the point of you might watch him
once but can you name those five Netflix
movies but that's you enough to name
them that's not the business model for
streaming though so with streaming you
get your income from um the from the
from the prescription from the subscri
new subscribers and you uh not just new
all your subscription money so you've
got a bill you got a 100 million
subscribers you get that money and every
year you get a you create a budget and
that right this money this this amount
of the subscription fee we're going to
spend on movies this year and this is
the movies going to about those movies
don't have to do anything they don't
have to be watched really um because
it's not about that you've you've
already got the money so that money
comes in right I'm I'm G to spend this
much of it making a
movie um with a cinema movie though
sorry the point is you're not really at
risk of losing money because a film
can't really bomb theyve already
subscribed if you put a movie in the
cinema it can lose money
and it can lose a lot of money if you're
a studio that's committed to putting a
billion dollars worth of movies a year
and you're putting next to zero dollar
movies a year and you're actually
burning through cash they can lose money
it's Amazon they can they they are
losing money and they're losing money
not putting Stargate in the movie
theaters right now yeah I would
agree money not doing Stargate right now
in general yeah full St and Robocop and
honestly our our biggest thing they're
losing money not putting Legally Blonde
out Reese is without her spoon right now
we need Reese with her spoon back what I
mean get get Jennifer Anon in it they're
good friends um it could be Legally
Blonde we need to see three Legally
Blonde women in there that would be
funny it'd be funny it'd be good but I I
just don't I
I talking to again talk to my source on
this and talk to the thing I can
completely understand why
I I think I could understand why they
don't want to do this because I think
it'll lose money and and I go back to
our original argument where she always
said was if they do a cinema movie and
it bombs will that kill the franchise
and I've never been able to get that out
of my head
um I do is there a silver lining in this
whole horrible
conversation that
is we're going to get a series that we
actually wanted in the first
place no because the I mean just just
the budget does not make it and that's
that's the whole thing budget does not
necessarily make it so they don't need
to go spend a hundred $200 million on a
movie they could spend a 30 50 6080
million movie like The Creator just did
and that way they're going to make money
back that way the the people that
already love Stargate that are going to
put their asses in a seat for this movie
they're gonna make their money back
everybody else is there if it's if it's
the right amount of budget they're good
TV show that changes everything if if we
go to MGM plus and
it's it it doesn't get what it deserves
or even half of
that we're getting a shell of a show and
we cannot afford to have a shell of a
show because that's what I that's what I
don't even know if Stargate Infinity
counts as anything but that's the
definition of a shell of a show it
didn't even pay attention to what
actually goes on in Stargate and and so
on so forth things like that I I'd be
worried that we're going to get
something like that something that's
just
not well this is speculation then but
penguin and a Parker were desperate to
do this we know Mark Fergus and this has
been confirmed by people like um Jenny
styven and a few other um insiders have
said penguin and Parker were involved
with this they did the development work
they had a development contract but
something happened last Christmas and it
seems that penguin and Parker walked
away that that's that's what it looks
like now we weren't sure we're not we're
still not 100% certain but it looks like
they may be walked away last
Christmas
um we know some of the arguments were
over
budget we know that that was what was
causing the hiccup at the time that Mark
Fergus was saying look are we doing a
movie or a series or both am I put is
this going on prime or is it going on
MGM Plus or is it going a freey for
God's sake just tell me where it's going
and I
will the I will pitch it to where it
goes you know just tell me what I'm
doing what budget are you giving me I
would love something like about eight
nine 10 million dollars an episode I
think that's the perfect came back with
five and the the feeling at the time was
they'd probably drop on around seven
which is what Star Trek was getting at
the time but now that would probably
that would be squeezed now because that
was you know 18 months ago and it was
all still wot Rosie and everyone still
thought they could spend anything they
wanted on streaming F series then it
would just grow you know but you know
that we'd be looking at six or seven
million dollar an episode now I
think um if if they supported it if they
really thriven into it but we know from
Apple in the
foundation they can do an awful lot with
$45 million an episode if they're
clever with the decision making that
this studio goes through Apple we don't
hear any drama coming out of apple we
hear negative drama coming out of apple
no what kind of drama do we hear coming
out of this they're not the same studio
and they're not going to spend $5
million the same way we we know that
just from Wheel of Time we know that
just from rings of
power we know how their mind works and
their mindset is not the same as Apple
so because Foundation is the perfect
example of you don't need that seven
eight n 10 12 $13 million talking minus
one not minus one excuse me Monarch um
kind of money to do something thing you
only need that four or5 million like I I
Melvin don't kill me but Foundation
looked and was 10 times better than
anything Monarch pulled off in that show
for almost a for no not almost for
literally a third of the price per
episode and they did way more and
and Amazon is not proven to us at all
that they are willing to
even attempt to get in that kind of head
space to make something not even not not
even the right heads space that's like
before actually getting into the actual
production pre-production anything
writing things down they haven't even
gotten the right head space yet they're
not in the right they're not in the
right playing field they're they're
playing soccer while it's actually the
basketball court like it that they don't
know what's going on you mean volleyball
all the above you also mean that I mean
these are still the second biggest
streaming platform on Prime they are the
are the second biggest there's you know
there's Netflix then there's not far
behind Amazon and then a bit behind that
Disney you know so they are a player
that but it seems to me that they've
they look at Netflix and go well just
keep spending the money keep spending
the money and Netflix is still naughty
for that they waste money hand over fist
it's the reason they started losing us a
million subscribers a month at a certain
point yeah but I mean I would say that
about three years ago they realized the
way streaming was going and they've
shown the other providers how to do it
um you know and they've saved so much
money on their um their their their sub
their
um uh storing all the actual data what's
it called it's G brain G out my head um
they save so much money on that though
they started turning a profit again
which has just been insane Netflix never
really made money a lot of money but um
you know it's I just think I don't know
I don't think this is necessarily as a
terrible thing that they're not going to
go ahead with a movie it's just going to
be one more
delay it's just when will they actually
announce it and and again this source
that we have to say is a rumor we can't
confirm it at the point at this point
doesn't think it'll be this year that we
even get like a fullon
announcement is it can you either of you
imagine any reason why that would
be
just in-house
bickering what else I don't know they
don't know where to go with it they
don't know what to do so that's
it yeah I
think I suspect that the issue here is
that they weren't prepared when the
strikes ended they've taken a while to
get going again after the strikes and
now because they've basically decided to
reset
everything um
they've got their hands full with what
they were already doing never mind
trying to do something new and I think
it might actually come down to a simple
as that they just don't and now they've
just let go um
7800 you know people in redundancies to
try and cut
costs because that's what all the
studios are now trying to do is
desperately trying to cut costs and
again they're not going to focus on
taking a risk on something new right now
when they don't physically even have the
people maybe to do
it you know because they've just they've
just sacked a bunch of people
so
yeah I think that's the way I think that
might be just it might just be as simple
as that it's going to take another 12
how many films will he supposed to be
bringing out a year Amazon specifically
after purchasing MGM was it something
like 12 or something they wanted to do a
year they were going to do five six
billion for for that billion that was
just Amazon Amazon were going to do five
or six cinema movies a year yeah and the
other ones were straight to streaming
were they I remember I've read something
that about them hoping to do 12 Movies a
year but not specifically probably right
yeah that billion dollars that was being
specifically ring fenced which is why I
think Stargate was always going to get a
cinema movie in the first place I've
said that a million times haven't I um
was because he had this billion quid and
they just thought we may as well just
spend that that's not okay but I think
they've decided now that we're not going
to spend that billion quid on cinema
movies I'd be I think it'll be maybe a
case by casee basis I think they'll
literally come along and go okay this
movie feels like a cinema movie let's go
for it and
then and then other films like Roadhouse
Roadhouse was always supposed to be a
cinema movie always when was it
announced it was going to go to stream
like a week ago it comes I still think
that's a tactic I there's a few people
that come out saying that's just a
tactic to get more people to go watch it
because once again it's hard to get
people to go into theaters right now you
convince people they're going to be able
to watch it in a week or two and then
they're like oh wait wait wait wait this
there so many people loved it we have to
go to a theater now all right I'll go to
a theater that's what happened to Avatar
Pay-Per-View price on that Prime
nowadays depends 20 sorry sometimes it's
about 20 quid for a movie when it's
still on at the
cinema um but yeah they'll probably
it'll probably go on Prime is rental for
about10 pound when it comes out and
don't much yeah but I mean compared to a
Cinema ticket it's still less than a
Cinema ticket ah see this is whenever I
have to I have to put this in people's
minds go back to the movie theaters
because it's cheaper to do that than to
pay for all these streaming services
because all these different big chains
if you have a cinemar chain you go see
two movies a month for free if you have
a Regal uh C Regal Cinemark if you have
a Regal unlimited um membership whatever
it's called $23 a month and every movie
is only 50
cents I go
See's even better odion around here so
any film is five pound will go and see
but the problem is go and see but also
if you don't have a fancy pass or
anything every Tuesday typically at
large change chains of theaters they
have movie Tuesdays or discount movie
Tuesdays it's it's four five six seven
bucks for a ticket instead of 15 18 20
bucks come on y'all this is an
interesting point n's make do we Game of
Throne it and do they throw in a load
more violence and sex and make it for a
more grownup audience I've just watched
a series on um Netflix
um oh the [__] was it
called it's like an action comedy series
obliterated
obliterated um I watched the first
couple of episod I watched about halfway
through the the first episode thinking
this is stupid it's like the aam it felt
like a 19 1980s episode of The A Team B
with boobs and swearing and drugs and
and really violent so I was like oh
they've made a series that I this going
to remind me of the 18 but that I'll
watch now and that's what the and so
halfway through the first episode
thinking this is stupid by the end of
the first episode I was like we're going
to watch the next episode though right
and we by the end of the second episode
I was like this is the greatest TV show
that's ever made because it's like the
18 but I want to watch it now because
it's got sex and boobs and things in it
it's actually really good it's stupid
it's full turn brain off eat popcorn and
giggle at the
silliness but it's
good would they and the popularity of
things like the boys uhuh dare do
something like that with
Stargate or any big franchise they kind
of done it a bit with Star Trek well
they done a bit with Star Wars with
Andor
yeah first scenes in a strip club like
Star Wars I never done that before you
know um I I think there's room for it
but that would be like doing your
miniseries in MGM Plus or something or
your miniseries wherever the hell you
end up putting it I don't necessarily
think that should be if if people have
an itching for it they should have an
itching for it but I think
the uh someone mentioned earlier uh the
amount of military folk that watch
Stargate obviously it's a big military
typee show you know oriented show huge
military base probably that watches it
those people see that serious stuff on a
daily basis part of the reason they
watch it is because they get to see
quote unquote that series of stuff
happening but they don't have to like
you know they don't have to absorb it a
second time for the day they they can
have a little bit of a chuckle while
they're still dealing with serious stuff
because st's still does serious stuff
world ending events Planet ending events
this ending whatever you know whatever
going on oh god
um Newport County are Welsh and they're
four leagues below
us soon to be three yeah seem to be it
might be
three Newport [__] County anyway we
can't win a game but but yeah man
it's 100% I I I think I agree with you
um I wonder whether they could do
something like what they've done with
Star Trek though and but hopefully do it
better the idea of all the different
Star Trek series is that they've sort of
pitched every different series at a
different demographic so Discovery was
always supposed to be a slightly younger
demographic the card was supposed to be
like my demographic the people that
watch TNG first time around then we did
the cartoon that was you know for you
know and and then they but each series
was pitched and the idea being if you
don't like one and they actually said
this repeatedly curtzman keeps saying it
and Jee Roden BR kid keeps saying it if
you don't like one Star Trek just watch
another star Star Trek ha and now that
drives me up the wall I could imagine a
lot of soldiers and stuff being put on
report for doing that sort of thing just
imagine them changing their badges
around on a military base
yeah on the arm just I don't want to be
a sergeant anymore fin been a colonel um
I don't like that Stant but but could
they do could the idea be that they're
going to do something like that now
start get because that was what we heard
at first that was the first rumor that
was going around was that they were
going to do they were looking at Star
Trek and Marvel and they wanted to do
that sort of thing where it would be
looks and the thing is with with Amazon
they've got two or three different
places they could put different series
they could put a series on freee and one
on Prime and one on MGM plus and have
very different types of
Show franchise to to to kind of tie it
in to something that we've talked about
as a as the channel as of recent is Brad
freck and Wright he doesn't necessarily
have to showrun something but wouldn't
it be night nice if he wasn't
necessarily like he might not be the
Kevin [__] of all of it but if he's at
least somebody that can consult on all
these things and bridge the gap he
doesn't need to be in charge of it all
necessarily but if he's if he's got a
fingerprint on everything that would not
only be Goodwill for your old fans it
would it would tell the new fans hey we
do have confidence in this again because
that's once again you just want to show
confidence because two or three years of
edging look where we've been now you
know
uh I don't necessarily like the because
a couple people said like don't follow
the Star Trek model don't follow the
Star Trek model I like the idea of the
following the Star Trek model but do do
do it correctly plan things out plan
plan your work then work your plan and
don't do it just like all right let's
just to Spaghetti at a wall and see what
sticks you know because that's what I
feel like Star Trek's done uh but but it
could
Star Trek fans don't care about Canon
and details don't
worry reason I haven't I remember in the
second episode of thinging 35 years ago
when you said that wasn't right and
somebody else said thing and that
Jeffree shoot tube should go left not
right and I like no sci-fi fans really
really focus on detail and we remember
very important thing Jay there should
not be that that much empty space on
bard of discovery
yeah there is a lot of empty space I'm
discovering Jeff Turbo Shot what turbo
sh it was open space yeah those those
turbo shafts in the discovery was stupid
there was just massive empty spaces with
these things going there it was just
ridic how big is that ship it's like um
Star Trek uh five when they go and they
have you know they have the boots and
they go up and they just see like deck
99 and do 103 and like whoa who whoa how
big's the
Enterprise it hasn't got 300
decks um I was just like Details Matter
and that was one of the things that St
Brad R always talks about with Stargate
is that actually these things do matter
you establish a rule and okay mistakes
will happen you might even change things
but if you change something have a
reason for it um but the rules matter
you establish rules and you follow them
Star Trek just went rules
smols I've got a list of
rules sorry I just last night I Nick
Cage I love all his recent movies since
uh Mandy Colorado of space and willly
Wonderland came out I I've just been
loving everything he's put out prisoners
of the Ghost Land looked like one of
those fun weird movies that he did kind
of in that same vein a couple years ago
and I've been wanting to watch it since
it came out and just never have I
watched it last night and it was the
epitome of that and I was just pissed
off for an hour and 40 minutes I hated
that movie socking much there was they
they didn't lay out any ground rules and
they sure held in stick to any of them
and it was just like rules the lack of
coherence was just like you know and and
I'll I'll put on my little Hollywood hat
and be like okay well there's something
Artful over here there's something
Artful over here I'm like the
cinematography looks good besides that
[__] this movie like it was it was bad
but anyway sorry I just was stuck in my
brain they did change that role ju it's
funny though isn't it with Stargate you
really have to when they've made a
mistake or they've changed something you
really have to like think about it and
go well
yeah okay they did change the three shot
rule because it was a story mechanism to
allow them to do things they did change
that um fair enough um but they never
really actually broke that rule but what
they said was that you need to do three
times quickly because it needs to build
up the energy or if if you allow it to
dissipate then you can do it again sort
thing so they don't really but with Star
Trek it's like I have to try to figure
out where they haven't broken Canon this
week it's it's a completely different
it's oh it's just star Stargate was
always way way better at it than than
that but
anyway times Brad Wright made it up as
it went along
so was all it's documentary uh Rob
Cooper and Brad Wright made it all up he
um it's not like they had a team of
writers with them going oh here's an
idea well we've that that that's just
talked about um star in this news I'm
going to have a video out in the next
couple of days where I'm going to try to
succinctly put all these ideas together
um as I said I haven't really done it
yet because I've been trying to find out
as much as I can and just nobody knows
anything um
so yeah I send me addresses I'll go get
some information yeah the one thing I
was thinking about though is you
remember I I have one of my sources is
um in marketing and they said just
before the um strikes ended they were
asked to review um a bunch of projects
that they were planning to for release
sort of thing in the next six months and
one of the things would have been
Stargate but they were told not to
review
Stargate
um at the time we wondered oh is that a
good thing or a bad thing is that
because they're canceling it or is it
because um they're about to release it
and we were like getting a bit excited
like maybe that means they're about to
actually they not maybe they're not
reviewing it because they're going to do
it and now it's like oh no they didn't
review it because they were canceling it
and it's like they they're not going
ahead with the idea that they were
having and they were told so the
marketing people were told not to
bother
and that was months ago I told you like
guys that so I really should have maybe
I was sometimes you know we have this
news and we want to see the positive and
we want to go maybe it's good thing and
in the backy ready going this is
probably a bad
thing but but yeah so let's see what
happens but I did want to talk a little
bit about the expanse before we go
because I dropped a video last night
basically saying that Amazon have
finally agreed um for oh I'm gonna say
it wrong again I want to say
Amron
Alon Amron is a stereo manufacturer than
I had a lovely stereo when I was a kid
Alcon of the company that make [__]
thing right
so Alon actually there's loads of
them Alon and Alon and alron and um so
they're quite easy to mix up but anyway
um the basically the The Story Goes that
um that Peter Moore is there any good
news man united are
winning they're winning from your
reactions yeah 32 that was the that was
me going yeah and then I then I was
pointing out that it's with the
[__] could hear it you were cheering
and going
that quiet
32 um but anyway so um yeah the sun came
up and um World War 3 hasn't kicked off
yet but it's probably going going to
so so don't don't get too excited
um it's
2024 we're
breathing and you know what was great
news that I was gonna just wait till the
end of the movie to embarrass you about
but you know what it's not even that
embarrassing because you
know we're we're we're twins birthday
twins I can't believe they're 25 already
I am 25 I was 25 last we that Jimmy turn
25 years old yesterday y'all thank you
very much mate thank you and I did thank
you all for my birthday wishes actually
I got Lo loads of messages thank you so
much I really appreciate that um uh I
don't know how Shelly knew it was my
birthday did it come up on my Facebook
or something probably I
got ah crap I need to remove that um but
I I got some lovely messages thank you
so much but now on the interwebs
internationally we all know when your
birthday is now yeah well well I told my
wife not to get me a present or a card
or anything she got she got me Bogle
nothing I didn't get a I didn't even get
a birthday card off the woman did you
get a birthday kiss
no I don't I don't I don't kiss and
tella um but um my wife is that really a
bad thing I
don't I I always wished a happy birthday
we'll put it that way in a different
way but but yeah not even a card so I've
divorcer um so that's um that's fine um
did did I get many presents you know how
many presents I got I got I bought
myself a snooker
que what a snooker que a q for playing
it's kind of like pool but on a bigger
table it's oh okay okay okay okay do you
know when you got American Sports and
then you've got proper sport right so
you've got pool that's
easy
we well we made the table much much
bigger and made it actually challenging
and then know you've got American
football with loads of padd in and it's
easy we removed all the padd in and call
it rugby and we basically are surprised
anyone survives I think you forget that
all these other things came first and
the American tends to be just the
refined version of all these things yeah
but according to the Americans they
invent stuff so you know how you guys
play basketball girls play netball here
and you know how you guys play
basball girls
play we play softball or like
round girls play rounders mate and you
call it baseball what is what Cricket
what about Cricket uh cricket it's not a
sport it's barely a game um I think
cricket was invented for the English to
sit round for a week and drink there a
gentleman social game isn't that most
sports though that's what the audience
always does yeah but we decided to do it
for a
week
Cricket watch
in you
can and no one wins and it can still be
a
draw I think you guys combined rounders
and Cricket to make baseball actually
yeah probably and then you did
the invite anyone to America always win
yeah that's the world series of baseball
so but you're the dominant superpower on
the planet
so yeah well you know you keep saying
American but you know what what I really
am and the reason America is the
dominating super super person on the
planet is because they got Texas baby
which which Texans make up the majority
of the United States military the vast
majority so
we superpower is because China keeps
having electric cars blow up yeah and
we've got the Scottish so we fill our
the Scottish with our military they're
the equivalent to
Texas yeah but do you really have the
Scottish because I feel like they want
to leave yall just as much as we want to
leave America sometimes yeah we just
luckily though they're skint so they are
they are they don't realize just how
much it costs to provide a police force
provide a
military
Texas we got all our nuclear submarines
and we're like we're not keeping them in
England they're dangerous got the
base they're all in
Scotland big nuclear bases in Scotland
yeah this radiation D have that there
have that in England screw that um
anyway um I hope this I hope the
Scottish don't leave I like I like
Britain I like being part of Britain
it's um I hear America is the United
States military is concerned about us
not sharing the new stealth technology
for our new
submarines yeah they're not very happy
with us our um our new submarines are
like three times then why don't you tell
about your
F22 yeah well they sell them to us at a
reasonable price
yeah uh the lightning twos anyway look
the expanse so I I I dropped the story
last week that obviously I've been
following this for about a year now um
and it looks
like exactly that the um Amazon still
held the TV and movie rights for the
expanse but Imron Amron Alon whatever
own a do own the IP so they they own the
the show the rights to the show um and
then you've got people like um Daniel
crap his name's gone out my head the sa
Corey
guys Danel
ab and Ty Franks Ty Franks um who are
the obviously original writers and then
you've got naron Shankar who is the um
who was the the the top guy at the show
then been trying to put a production
company together for a while but there
was never any movement because Amazon
still held the TV
rights Amazon look like they're about to
release the TV and movie rights back to
Alcon so that
freeze freeze the expanse to potentially
return is that something that we would
be interested in though at this point
yes so no um Harris have you ever even
watched the expans uh yeah the reason I
started watching Stargate was because I
just finished the expanse and I was like
I gotta figure something else that fits
in this boot and then then Stargate was
the big thing for MGM on Amazon and that
move just happened and I was like this
seems fun let me try it out should I
watch this or should I watch Farscape I
watched two episodes of Farscape I was
like this is really good but I think I
just I was pissed off that Netflix
hadn't I think I just rewatched Dark
Crystal or something and I was like I'm
pissed off at Muppets right now I can't
do it so I just kind of I went to
Stargate I've not looked back once I
probably should watch far but still yes
you should watch farc that is great and
hopefully that's going to come back at
some point if Amazon get their way it
will straight to freee um
but you there's there's so much Universe
there to expand but I the real question
I want to ask was if if it is
Apple um that go for it and they they
seem to be the only ones interested at
the moment but let's be honest Alcon are
going to have to finance and produce
something and then
potentially hopefully somebody will buy
a I'm hoping they do it in the
oldfashioned way of that they actually
buy a um maybe buy a miniseries and then
and then build from there but if if
Apple are willing and go is $50 million
do us a season and we'll see where we go
from there are Apple the perfect place
for this show to go could the expanse
actually finally find a home that suits
it look at the foundation price tag and
and not just the price tag and but just
look at the final product based upon
what they did with that price
tag I think the the expanse would do
wonderfully on Apple I think that the
way it moved from sci-fi to Amazon it
still did all right but it felt like
sci-fi Game of Thrones in the last two
seasons where those last two seasons
just weren't the same as those first
four um it's still decent still good
still better than most other things on
TV like the last two seasons of Game of
Thrones if you compare to those first
few seasons you're just like it's night
and day I I think Apple would actually
take the time and effort into making
this what it could and should be I guess
there's a lot of other streaming
services that if given the opportunity
they would try to streamline this as
fast as possible and I mean just just I
mean I I know Monarch we probably have
varying levels of uh opinions on but
still a very meticulous show that they
spend a lot of time effort on and one
that they probably green I think they
greenl it around Godzilla versus Kong
right and they've been working on it for
a while since maybe even right before it
uh so so even with a big franchise like
that they're willing to take the time
and it still looked amazing I still wish
that we could have gotten a lot more
from it but what we got looked amazing
uh and was well made at least and I I
think that would just proves Apple would
be able to do it and do it well well I
mean Melvin we've got the sort of TV
shows that apple have done in the last
few years Sci-Fi TV shows Silo first
season they've they've done a second For
All Mankind has had what five seasons
something like that it's it's just had
the fifth one I think yeah yeah and
Foundation is just getting its third
season Invasion has had at least two
seasons I think is that that going to be
a third one next year C got three or
four seasons
um oh God it's to honest it goes on and
on and on really um this is a this is a
streaming platform I think my point is
do you really think For All Mankind
would have had four five seasons on any
other platform not at
all I
age well
imagine Netflix for me that is getting
cancelled after the first season all
over
it but apple is pushing on For All
Mankind has not exactly been tearing up
trees popularity Wise It's had four
seasons and it's really only in the last
year or so it's sort of come into my
sphere of knowledge that people keep
going you got to watch the show you got
to watch the show and I finally got
around to trying to watch it it's not
like it was
um um Ted lasso with everyone was
talking about it is it it's and winning
Awards and blah blah blah it's a good
show but it was quietly a good show but
Apple have stuck with it
um I just
think maybe there's that that apple is
the perfect place for it because Apple
will know what they've got and they'll
stick with it they'll have a five season
plan and they'll actually do it you know
whereas I don't think Amazon would have
done well Amazon didn't Amazon had the
expanse which is regularly voted one of
the most popular and most realistic
sci-fi shows ever made and they canceled
it
well hit those like button guys yeah
like
y hi my little rant what do you guys
think though am I talking [__] or or is
this just the perfect place for me no I
I think you're right I just I'm trying
to gather my thoughts you know my ADD
self I I get them all ready and then
they fly right out the other ear and
then they have to come back but you know
it just takes a second sometimes uh I I
I think you're right with apple though
in the sense of they actually stick with
shows far more than any other streaming
service does not it's just streaming
cable whatever it is because when a one
of the things that happened with this
whole strike that that sag just voted on
three years is your average run of your
TV shows if they if they're successful
they'll run for about three years and
then contracts have to renew every main
character not not your secondary not
your ancillary not your guest stars not
your recurring stars but your main cast
they have to have I think it's like a 20
or 40% pay raise whatever it may it
might even be more than that and and so
on so forth that's just does not apply
to them it applies for everybody that's
worked there I think under uh iy and
things like that as well so you're
you're not just doing that for your
actors you're doing that for your
producers you're doing that for people
just working on set everybody gets paid
more after those three or four years
and the the I mean just look at the is
that going to be realistic for something
like rings of power whenever you go back
for fourth season and how much is
everybody getting paid how much do the
show cost how much is everything you
have to raise it by 20% you have to
raise it by 40% in that fourth season
you have to have something super um
successful or financially successful not
just viewership successful but
financially successful to continue that
on almost any other
platform best thing about apple
plus their GDP is more than I think
people have made the comment their
annual income is more than most
countries make every single year they're
fine with cash that's not even their
that that's that's not even their
mindset even that's just an extra backup
for them their mindset going into making
their TV shows like we've mentioned is
quality over quantity for every single
TV show ex except I know Melvin I'm
sorry except for Monarch that's the
that's quality over quantity but it was
still well made they they just could
have done better so much potential
anyway I apple is excellent in in in
prioritizing the quality aspect over the
quantity and they allow the shows to go
longer because they don't Ty like
Foundation $50 million budget $45
million budget they're not spending as
much on these shows because they have a
cast of people that care about what
they're making and those people are not
there to make money off of these shows
they're people's pet projects these are
these are projects people go to because
they truly care not just about the
medium of film not just the art aspect
of film or television all the above
they're there to make a project that is
going to be on their resum res that they
can be proud of and that's what Apple's
really good about and they know that and
they're not going to spend a whole bunch
of money on a lot of series like a lot
of people do but they will continue to
push these series until they're done and
in the right aspect of what the story
needs it to be you know uh that inight
shy Milan and and the Jason Mamoa series
if it was not Jason Mamoa he wouldn't
have gotten three seasons of Frontier on
Netflix I'm shocked that he ever did um
but that's the whole thing it wasn't
ever going to go past that third season
on Apple plus uh is it C I don't know if
it got three or four seasons or what but
they allowed it to go long enough they
they that M9 shyon show wouldn't have
been able to go past a season one on any
other service and a lot of these shows
wouldn't but Apple allows them to not
just because they have all that extra
cash to do it that doesn't even play
into it yet it might come into the play
in the future but as of now they they
truly care about what they're making and
that's weird because you know we're half
pissed off at Amazon for being Mr
Corporation all the time Apple's bigger
Corporation arguably
and they care it it just depends who you
hire to actually care and that's what
I'm talking about with the whole Amazon
mindset behind a lot of this their
mindsets not even in the right ballpark
they're play they're on the basketball
court thinking they're playing soccer
that's that's and apple is like all
right we're playing bad mitton and we're
on the badminton court we know what
we're doing it might not be some big
giant sport but we're doing it
correctly uh it just seem to me that
there's a big um
there's a bit of a dark angel
conversation going on in think the main
reason why Dark Angel was canceled when
it was was because of contracts and
things and I know like Jessica Albert's
apparently contract was up for
renegotiation by the end of the second
season for some reason and she wanted a
lot more money and uh there was there
was a lot of issues like that with dark
angel so it sort of the the costs were
about to go up when actually viewing
figures had been steadily decreasing and
that was the main reason why Dark Angel
got canceled well I think think even cuz
I said three years I think three years
might be the new thing in the contract I
think it might have been two years and
then the reup was actually having to
happen something that a lot
of because but start the next generation
was that it was two years for everybody
and then reup took two years so um
that's why you see a lot in sci-fi shows
at that period that you would see a lot
of changes at the end of the second
series of series that people would leave
and new actors would come in and that
you'd see a big big rejig star Atlantis
star Atlantis yeah You' you'd see a lot
of rejigs even even sg1 it was signed
off two seasons and then they all
renegotiated and that's when production
companies changed and and and and things
change it's it's it's it's quite common
that you get that and the idea being
that if show few seasons it's going to
run on for seven or or you know all the
five or whatever I was that's not true
anymore but streaming services my
understanding is streaming services
don't negotiate contracts like that and
haven't done Netflix have never done
that they they have to they have if if
they're uh abiding by sag actor if
they're hiring sag actors for their
shows they have to abide by that and so
on so forth if it's a sag production II
production it's those yeah yeah I think
they they they I think Netflix tried to
get around it different ways to be
honest we'll see yeah um they somebody
told me that Netflix do it more like
each season is more like a movie from
contractual point of view rather than a
series so they and that's how they
approach the the contracts with a lot of
Netflix and a lot of other stream
services but I don't really know what he
means by that so let's not get into it
but that some it's one of those things
that you know when I'm not really
listening to well I get told talking to
because I'm on um a WhatsApp group with
four with 15 different sources working
in different aspects of the um
15,000 15 yeah 15 sources 15 um and from
different aspects 15 so um and they they
work in lots of different parts of the
industry now they almost all of them
worked at MGM and they all got sacked
and they've just g into the atmosphere
so it's brilliant for me because I got
but they talk about stuff and that's
that group isn't for me this is their
group and they've let me into it um so
um so they talk about stuff and I'm just
like I have no [__] clue what they're
talking about half the time they're
talking about an industry that for me
I'm looking on the outside makes no
sense it seems back I've worked in you
know different businesses and things my
whole life and to me the way they do
things is just
backwards um but I mean literally
literally though I mean the easiest
thing to just bring up the strikes again
the the one thing that maybe was kind of
like well the the the Studios have a
point is like residuals how do residuals
how would residuals work in any other
industry they they don't they
legitimately just don't there's that's
one of the like the backwards things of
Hollywood is like it is very niche in
its own not not just in like its own
Zeitgeist and how it like shows the it's
niche in like a non- niche way but like
where it's it's niche in the way it
operates is I guess what I'm trying to
say uh because it does not operate
entainment industry in a whole is is
different isn't it because you the prod
to sell is different it's it's it's not
flange you know it's not something that
you can hold in your hand is it it's
something but but then
again I I just even if it is different
like that I don't know if the economics
like residuals don't exist in other
Industries but they also don't exist
within this industry in the
entertainment industry for people that
don't have their face on a screen or
people that aren't physically or or
executive producer or something like
that if you're not a head honcho a film
you might have put twice as much work as
somebody that was executive producing a
film on on that film and you got paid
while you were there but you're not
getting residuals big fancy stars are
because they got their face right there
but then they got paid how much more
than you on the day how much more did
they get paid throughout the entire
shoot how much bonus did they get
because it did this in theaters as well
and they're still getting residuals I'm
an act like I'd love hey residuals are
fun keep paying me but also let's be
realistic here is that an actual model
that is first acceptable for the world
especially if we want to in these try
times and in this the scarcity and the
uh the lack of um what what what did you
call it earlier what crisis the monetary
crisis of some
sort cost of living crisis that's the
one so young godamn it py a bill boy I
do they're every other month out here
though and daddy paying your bills
doesn't count it
doesn't I'm out here boy but uh he's
he's he's got a be it he I'm sure he
pays his own bills
you know
uh
I I lost my try to
thought y y it doesn't take much it
doesn't take much do you remember the
old days when uh when all the bad guys
had those big those like mustache with
be I'm trying to be cast a villain too
hell whatever
whatever
[Music]
cats right so what did we decide the
expans is good for apple or bad for
Apple I forget or or apple is good for
the expanse or bad for the expanse I
think it's good for the expanse I think
both are good potentially good we'll see
I think yeah I think haris said is
straight up though considering the other
things they've done to me it just
completely makes sense it just it just
feels
right for apple and I know people don't
like the business model of apple and and
apple as a as a company and I get that
but you actually look at what they
produce on this streaming platform for
me they're playing the long game they
want they they're not looking at Netflix
and desperately trying to chase Netflix
like Disney did and they're not trying
to achieve everything in the first year
they're steadily trying to grow a
platform and I think it is a platform
that will eventually
merge um with other platforms to make it
you
know worth watching but um in the M time
they
but but to compare MGM plus to
Apple MGM plus could do what Apple are
doing if if Amazon have got any sense
they need that Ted lasso show though and
that show could be
Stargate they need that show that's
actually going to get them recognized
when Ted lasso came out a lot of people
like apple have got their own streaming
platform have they um you know and
that's what that's what this MGM plus
needs it needs its Ted lasso it needs a
show it needs its Star Trek it needs a
show that people actually go out of
their way to watch and if this is the
plan over Amazon I get it
mindset yeah we need if only mate I I
I've always said give me Stargate I
don't give a crap if it's a movie series
whatever I I would prefer a series a
movie made me nervous but the way I saw
it was good it's if it's good it'll work
at the end of the day and that's what
should actually matter Star Trek if it
was good it would be better the problem
is it's not and a lot of what they're
doing isn't very good
Marvel there is no such thing as
superhero fatigue there's bad movie
fatigue because a lot of the movies
they've done in the last five years have
not been very
good um and that
people neither of their shows
particularly no which is why they
they're now desperately trying to do a
reset and they're trying to move back
towards the Netflix sort of era of TV
shows it feels like to me they've
realized they're [__] up so they seem
to be trying to reset but we've had a
long time of you
know we've had about five years of
really bad product and people will you
know that that is the end of the world
you know like is doing his best what
who's R&B Robert marett he I he's just
he's great he's the guy we talked about
that should come on uh do the Star Trek
versus Stargate debate that we just
mentioned at the brief uh was it last
Sunday or last Cinema SC scoop one of
the two he's I was about to type it but
he's he's the he's one of the people I
probably respect on this platform more
than most he's just he's great for when
it comes to film uh the Duke of do
discourse the Somalia of sci-fi the he's
he has a bunch of different names I I
love the guy he's great great check it
out I don't think I I I don't think I've
I used to watch him I think but it was
ages ago post geek Singularity or the
Brunet work yeah possibly I try not to
watch other people's YouTube channels
though particularly because it then sort
of I find
it it's it's it's sort of like um they
get into my head and I sort of like will
end up following or I you know it it it
changes my I want to have an honest
opinion that's my opinion I don't want
to get um what's the word I'm looking
for um you don't want your perspective
influencing
yeah I don't want to be influenced by
other perspectives and things I want I
want it to be a true me you know I like
to try to get different perspectives
from as many different spots as possible
then yeah I just find it like um when
you're doing this and you're trying to
to to to run it and also to be to do
something that's a bit different I I
want to do what I do you know I don't
want to do what other people do so I I
try I used to watch loads because I was
then I pick I I was picking when I was
trying to figure out how to be a
YouTuber and I think but then I found it
but the the problem is I just don't have
time to listen to lots of different
YouTube videos because I'm either doing
a 40 hour week or I'm doing I actually
figure out I do 25 hours a week on
YouTube and I've also got a 40h hour a
week job it's like it's like 70 hours of
my week um and wife expects to see me
and
things it's only for birthdays every now
and then right yeah yeah just yeah every
now and again when I have a birthday a
few hundred sub
you won't have to have a full-time job
do this as
full-time uh if only I think YouTube
specifically don't want um YouTubers to
do that it
seems every time they change their rules
it seems that I get less money and I
didn't get that much money to begin
with but um they Chang they keep
Chang there also the fact that in
America it's is it 500 subs and yeah
3,00 um 3,000 hours whereas everywhere
everywhere else except for us and Canada
it's still 1,000 subs and 4,000
hours which means I'm more than halfway
there and y'all just got to come help me
out you know that means got too much you
don't have
to no don't subscribe you don't have to
subscribe to come to me here every
Sunday what's the point come over the
I'm not over I'm not here all the time
news yeah we
go there are links in the description
for everything but not sci-fi Quest
because I forgot um
yes I will add a link and I will throw a
link on the Community page as well for
you Melvin so I really appreciate
you yeah why why you what what what you
doing because Ahsoka had her arms
crossed for 89% of the entire Ahsoka
series well you going for unhappy but
hit like like 90s rapper instead by
mistake oh oh were you going for sexy
I'm not really sure what you were trying
to do um but yeah no guys go on
everybody um YouTubers need to
unionize I don't want to have to go on
stri though that's the thing that'll
just be somebody that want my money
though then would it yeah that's just
another layer of red tape all unions are
are an extra layer of bureaucracy sorry
yeah I mean you don't earn anything if
you if you're called on to strike you
don't really earn anything unions are
the definition of Good Intentions pave
the road to hell yeah good intentions
that make people homeless X2 just start
posting to X2 some people aren't a fan
they monetize for cre I I I might start
putting the live streams on X I did I've
done it once or twice we we've put
started putting the cinema scoops on
there three or four already so you got a
couple up yeah I might start doing that
I might start doing just like specific
ones um yeah 500 3,000 hours for
monetized audience or 1,4 hours for
AdSense oh that's the thing Ah that's
correct yeah yeah um but um but yeah I
don't know if I don't know if YouTube's
there's too many people are youtubing or
what but yeah the money it seem they
changed the rules around July last year
and I don't know about and I I know from
talking to other YouTubers because we do
talk to each other everybody's ad
Revenue just took and it's not record
and and and I think part of it is easier
for you to like get started but
also there's such a disperate
between us people like us especially
Melvin and I are like still pushing for
it you know versus I mean we're not even
comparable but versus Mr Beast versus
Mark robber versus these giant things
that are no point
lar well no I'm saying in the sense I'm
not saying comparable that's why I'm
saying like versus it's it's more so in
the sense
of it it's weird but YouTube is losing
its middle class just like the film
industry is right
now it's losing the ability for
YouTubers like me to be honest where I
where 30,000 a year ago would have been
insane well yeah years I talk you wrong
I love it and I've got a hobby that
earns me a nice little bit of money
usually then I can have a day off and I
you know I I don't work full time
anymore it's been extra at the Caravan
I've got a caravan yeah um doesn't
doesn't pay for that but I've got I've
also get an ex model for your son to
build yeah immediately it's like I'm not
building it you go build it it I do love
that looks out bought myself a a
thing that was YouTube money that was 15
quid um but you know I've got a hobby
that earns money how many hobbies earn
money normally Hobbies cost money yeah
you know but um so that's really cool
but
um well this one's still cast too but
the problem is though it is when you get
used to earning this much and then all
of a sudden you earn this much a lot of
YouTubers I do this because I love it I
don't really care um as long as I earn
enough money that the wife lets me have
my day off once a week to do it um or if
she's but if she get get like look you
can make pound a day at work you're only
making a couple hundred pound you need
to you need to go back to work this
isn't fair and that's what she was
basically saying at first was like look
I
know you you can't make enough money you
can earn more money at work so you need
to go to work but now I earn more money
not going to work that day so she's fine
with it the problem is if if you got
somebody else own they're used to
earning a grand a month and all of a
sudden they're only making
500 and they're not doing it because
they love it they're going to
stop I mean they're like it's not even
just like oh well but you're still
making 500 but they be like but but I
was making a grand and now I'm not so um
nothing's happened to Star Trek
Studios uh that will still happen at
some point but um I think sometimes I I
released news that something is planned
to happen and then when it doesn't
happen like a month later people are
like oh everything in this industry
takes forever this will be something
that happens um
potentially in the next 12
months there's an idea with the Star
Trek calling it Star Trek Studios and
buying out kurtzman that is um part of
the longer term plan with Paramount
knowing it'ss about to get sold and
you've got to remember as well that
Paramount Global don't want to be sold
they haven't got a choice so there there
are lots of things going on
restructuring lots of things because the
Redstone who
own um the bulk of the control and
shares have decided to sell and that's
this is not normally how big businesses
like this get get taken over or big when
we've had big merges like this before
it's not how this has happened so this
is a bit unusual so Paramount Global as
a company are desperately trying to
protect certain things and one of the
things they're looking at doing is
creating this Star Trek
Studios but there's so much up in the
air with powermount at the moment like
in the rest of the wider entertainment
industry there's so much up in the air
it's really going to depend on what
happens with
[Music]
um who who who is what Redstone decid to
do who ends up being the new owners
there's lots of things that are
happening but there's lots of things
like Star Trek Studios that are being
suggested because they're desperately
trying to protect themselves and Star
Trek is one of their biggest assets so
they've got to protect it and that's
where this idea has come from buy Out
curtzman Create Star Trek Studios move
the IP basically so Star Trek Studios
will own it
and then um and they could do TV and
movie um which they haven't never to
before and then when it does get sold
and potentially broken up they can
protect Star Trek that's the that's the
idea of this whether it happens or not
there's a lot of things going on between
now and then don't forget to hire Terry
matalas I don't think they're
going I spoke to somebody about Legacy
yesterday and I'm just going to get
called names again but spoke to somebody
about Legacy yesterday and they were
going yeah you're bang on this was
always the plan with Star Trek Legacy
and um Disney don't think they can sorry
um Paramount don't they can get metalis
to do
it um and I'm not even sure they've
asked
him they've just it seems to me that
they've just assumed he can't do it
because he's doing a lot of projects for
Disney now and he's got like two or
three projects on the go with Disney at
the moment what's he doing um he's doing
Escape to Witch
Mountain
series um he's producing and
writing um he's got another project with
them um oh that I forgot the name
of IMDb this [__] he's got several
projects that he's written scripts that
is written from years ago and apparently
Disney has basically said if Escape to
Witch Mountain does well um we'll run
off a couple we'll have a look at a
couple of other scripts so he's like oh
okay thank you um but what's the other
de what's the other one he's
got which
mountain yeah which mountain um
depending on who the producers are on
that I could find a way to my way into
that show hold up so yeah
he's hasn't got The Rock in it oh
Bewitched oh the last American vampire
is the other big project that looks like
it's it's going ahead and which is again
going to be a TV series and I think
that's Disney
um I can check real quick he's um 20th
Century Fox so disne he so it's Fox yeah
um which he was trying get made he get
something called the game that he was
trying to get made but I don't think
that's happening um but be witched is
still a possibility and I think
that's yeah so that's currently in so
basically he's got a bunch of deals and
and but the idea is none of this stuff
is sort of like green lit but Disney
have said through all their different
companies like Hulu Etc if wi Mountain
does well will will push you will push a
couple of other these these your way as
well I mean so he might have two or
three so he's he could so the feeling at
Paramount is that Disney have got their
claws into him that's basically what I'm
we told whether that's whether that's
what happens we'll see because I
actually think Taran metalis would kill
to do it if he if he can do it he'll do
it
but I'm not even sure P I've asked
him which is we'll
see um but I think we'll get a legacy
Announcement by the
summer we'll see though by June okay
we'll see again what happens with the
sale though unfortunately that might
scoer lots of things for Paramount at
the
moment but yeah all right guys I'm going
to go get some dinner all right nearly
two hours again so um it's it's Sunday
lunchtime um Tim Caffrey asking watch I
don't
know um I looked not long ago I don't I
don't know um as a Halo fan that shows a
travesty as as anybody seen the second
series of Halo yet well it's coming out
the eth is it the eth I'm rewatching
season one right now and I get that all
the people that played the games hate it
but coming from someone who only ever
played reach I like the show just fine
the last two episodes weren't great uh
it it it's one of those things where I
feel like it fits with newrick it's like
the people that actually like love the
cannon and the lore or hate it but
anybody else coming in is like that's a
decent sci-fi you know it's was like but
it's I
understand yeah and then it sort of PE
sort of again at the end for me but um
but I think season two will be good I
they
most it's mostly been the removal of the
helmet and the bum shot
for they said take his helmet off way
too much I think they're gonna keep
doing that but I think they're gonna
they took all the the the sex aspects of
it out because hey at least you can get
paid for more than just voice
acting need loads more action and loads
less of the actor taking his helmet off
yeah because it's contracted in
right thank you so much both of you it's
been alleged leg as always it's been an
absolutely amazing and um Stargate
Legacy um thank you everyone we've had
really good numbers had over 70 viewers
most of the videos that's really really
appreciate that still shows that people
want to talk about
Stargate um Lads has been fun I couldn't
sleep tonight and was interested in
being involved in live chat I thought
hey I thought you were going to go with
and you helped me go to sleep but then I
going how were you writing the comment
then but you didn't you were nice you
you had an opportunity there to be
horrible and you didn't take it thank
you Nate appreciate that sir uh Sarah
bye-bye Villa space whales hit that like
button go over and like people as well
yes Sarah like people people are lovely
like them all oh no I think she means
hit the like button like people as
[Music]
well um share the video where the hell
you like um we should have 70 likes
brain pain damn right um but not
everybody that watches us likes us so um
when I ever put staying watch us anyway
baby when I put a new video out I
immediately get two or three dislikes
before it's even
premieres same as me for every Star Trek
video
conveniently well it's weird is it but
I've got my channel that hate me so why
subscribe bug her off and watch
something else you idiot whether you hit
that or that it doesn't bother
me Ali either way yeah exactly um guys
thank you so so much um yeah we got 63
right now um have a lovely lovely day
enjoy your Sunday and we will see you
live next week and we will be on with
Harris on Wednesday for Cinema scoop so
don't forget to go over as always that
it will be shared on the channel as
normal Peace Love out see you